basically
the ibm folks including myself we are
pushing for
algorithms part that's a long story and
anna karamanska from nyu
and her students they helped us out with
theory
so it was kind of really like
combination of joining forces
and also ravi who is now at mit was our
student at that time and
was helping with running experiments
but basically it all started with
questions you keep asking yourself what
would have happened
if history was different so you probably
read uh
jorge luis borges maybe not but there is
a story
one of his famous stories called garden
of forking pass
have you read it in any case uh
the idea is like he's talking about some
strange book written by some chinese
emperor where it's like total mass
there is no logic and that seemingly
bottom line
the emperor was trying to write a book
where all possible trajectories
the whole tree in the history would be
reflected that's why characters
that are dead in first chapter
are alive on the third and anyway so if
you think about it this way
and ask yourself so what what what would
happen if you backtrack in the
decision tree of ai field
and make different choices at critical
points what would have happened
i mean essentially it's what's going on
right now because you can say well
we can go all the way back to the model
of neuron
mcauliffe and pitts and say that let's
redefine that
and let's make it more sophisticated in
various
ways more biologically plausible black
just talked about
one way too look at that capsules are
indeed relevant here
that's why i mentioned them various ways
of
looking into neuronal unit
and modeling it in some way
in more details and better whatever
better means
that's a separate conversation but yeah
we could make different design
choices at that level
next question as well learning
algorithms
we all know that back propagation for
now is well
pretty much standard and most of
software implements it
and for good reasons it does seem to
work well but still the question is
um well there are many other
optimization methods
that could have been used right so what
if
we tried something else and people tried
uh including us and i'll talk about that
story
and the gist of it is i think it's
important sometimes
to look at the garden of working paths
try to go back and see what if the
decision tree would choose a different
range
just saying well this is more like
you all probably have seen it multiple
times before when the interview was uh
jeff was giving this interview about
issues with back propagation though it
was i think in the context of
supervised versus unsupervised learning
but essentially he was totally thrashing
back propagation
saying that we need to throw it all away
and start again
well that's not fake news i can send you
the link but
in any case yeah i mean
jeff likes to say things like yeah i
need to throw it away and start
and he was saying that i'm pretty sure
that the next advance in
neural nets gonna be probably done by
some student who is
sitting in the audience is deeply
suspicious about everything i'm saying
and he's right so please be deeply
suspicious
about everything we're saying sorry
just to be clear i mean what jeff was
talking about that
uh interview which he didn't actually
know he was mean
that's not fair and the second thing uh
that he was ultimately arguing for
unsupervised
that's what i said it was a context of
supervised versus unsupervised
saying that if you treat everything as
supervised and you
then you use back propagation but what
if it's unsupervised then what do you do
i mean today's uh
supervised unsupervised reinforcement
learning
yeah that's right actually unsupervised
encoders by the way
here is a good thing and gael will talk
more about that
but here is a little bit of alternating
minimization mafia
so there is not the only way to train
even auto encoders
and actually let me just continue and
then i say where it's coming from
well with bad propagation i mean of
course there is always wrong
something is wrong with everything i
mean nothing is perfect
so it's pretty good but well people
complain about
if you motivated by biological
possibility if that's a question
of course it doesn't fit the bill and
the list of shortcomings is long
and i don't want to go into that blake
already covered
quite a few and even just looking at
their last
year nips paper well new ribs i just
cannot
switch to calling the good old nibs by
this strange new name but
never mind um so there was a
paper by sergey pertunov and timothy
lillcrap
and jeff hinton and few coasters uh
where they were trying to assess
scalability of several more biologically
plausible algorithms
including different flavors of target
propagation i'll talk about that a bit
more
and the arguments why they are not
biologically plausible among many other
things is
well first of all if you think about the
algorithm itself it only
works on weights so it doesn't
explicitly model any neuronal activity
and it kind of assumes that neural
activity is deterministic function
of the input which is not the case i
mean it's extremely simplified version
so even if you have an algorithm where
the neuronal activity is at least noisy
and somehow explicitly updated
that probably would be a bit better
again it's just like tiny bit i don't
want to even call it biologically
inspired it's like tiny bit inspired
the weight transfer problem yes that's a
separate problem we're not gonna address
it in our algorithm but target probe
and feedback alignment they address it
that's the problem that you have
same weights when you go up and down the
neural net and that's not exactly the
case in real neural networks but again
blake is a better person to discuss
those details there are many other
issues
like you need precise cloaking between
feed forward and backdrop faces
it's not exactly what's going on in real
brains violation of dale's law and so on
and so forth
even if you don't care about
neuroscience and you just want efficient
learning algorithm
uh there are still some issues
although people could argue that there
are many approaches to overcome those
issues and that's true
vanishing gradients i know so that's uh
always a debate either it's still a
problem or not
uh but even though it might be
very much alleviated by elastins and
other
approaches as long as you have
chain of gradients and this chain can be
long
and your matrices can be ill-conditioned
there are always
it's always a pandora box you may have
exploring or vanishing gradients if you
have that long chain and that does
happen apparently especially in
reinforcement learning especially in
non-stationary enforcement learning
that's kind of the case where the
vanishing gradients seem to bother
people a lot
i have no i don't have personal
experience but that's what i keep
hearing
so it would be nice to get rid of that
kind of once and for all
if possible um there
good old question about what do you do
if you have binary functions if you have
any kind of non-differentiable
non-linearities and computing gradients
is just not
convenient you have to do something like
with binary you have to do
um straight through estimators
essentially
ignoring those bad non-differentiable
functions
or some other tricks if you had some way
of just dealing with those things
locally
without having to take chain of
gradients again maybe it would be more
convenient
and last but but not least it would be
nice to have some
release and weight updates again people
may say well there are various
algorithms that
essentially gonna process mini batches
in parallel between layers
like once one layer processing one mini
batch the other is processing the other
one
but it's still not the parallelism at
the level of the same mini patch
anyway people tried different approaches
starting from actually jan's
thesis where he mentioned back
propagation but he also mentioned that
we could have just formulate constrained
uh version
of the optimization problem for neural
net learning
and then we can rewrite it as lagrangian
and then in principle we can solve it
with various methods
later on he tried to develop the target
propagation algorithm
which didn't immediately work that well
in terms of performance
and then well yeah yoshua had a paper
with students on different target
propagation
uh with somewhat improved results and
then the whole kind of
chain of uh papers including that paper
that i just mentioned
by sergey barton of and uh this one at
the last news
where they made yet another twist on
their different target propagation
so the bottom line with target
propagations was that they were
introducing activations hidden units as
explicit variables
and they were trying to essentially not
only optimize weights but optimize
values of activations
to fit the proper target what they
should have been
so there are many more methods that have
this
common property of introducing auxiliary
variables um
the list goes on but i mean one of the
papers that kind of
i think started this uh line of uh
research recently was 2014 paper at the
aztecs
the method of auxiliary coordinates by
career per pinyani network
so essentially they just took the same
formulation as
uh i think gianlechan had in his
scissors lagrangian form
and uh actually not even lagrangian they
replaced their weights i'll show the
equation later
replace the weight by the same kind of
common weight so
essentially and try to optimize that
there are many other methods after that
and perhaps not everything listed now
because since we had this paper out
uh those methods just
multiply like rabbits on archive uh so
when we submitted to icml we immediately
found the other day another paper in
icml format
talking about yet another auxiliary
variable method
but it was okay the problem is that most
of those methods they seem to be offline
so they batch uh so they are not really
scaling to really large data sets and
they are not really scaling to any
continual learning if you want to
continue learning
at least as far as i know at that point
and with target propagation methods
they are different they are also
introducing auxiliary variable methods
but they have now
two sets of weights unfortunately it's
not clear how to write a one objective
function
that drives target pro target prop is
formulated
in terms of local updates i mean it's
probably possible to write it but
it's not that immediate and
unfortunately as
uh intel's paper showed
it didn't perform that well as compared
aspect propagation on certain standard
benchmarks
so people kept trying including us
and my manager kept asking me like why
did i waste
my own time and time of so many people
for more than a year on something that
just doesn't work
so next time i decided not to mention
this project at all and we kept working
so finally thanks to many students
and months of experiments things started
taking some shape
and here is roughly the idea again at
that high level the idea is
quite common to several approaches what
will be unique
actually is that our auxiliary variable
approach is online
that seems to be the first online and
well thanks to anna karamanska we have
some theory
apparently again first time showing that
their online stochastic automatic
minimization actually will converge
i guess i mean it's not that terribly
striking results
but it was nice to know so
you introduce explicit variables
that stand for your activations and
essentially you separate
here for the nonlinear part
part will be called codes so that's kind
of you just take the linear
transformation of the previous layer you
get your
code variables then you apply
nonlinearity
with noise and you get them uh
actually those codes are you can say
that they are um
gaussian variables in a bayesian network
if you that fit for a neural net
essentially is based now
which is pretty much the case that just
in regular neural nets
a base net with deterministic
conditional probabilities
pretty much except for the last layer
and once you have now those noisy
activation variables the chords you can
alternatingly minimize
your weights and those variables
idea is like as old as
i don't know any kind of alternating
minimization algorithms
uh which the first thing that come to
your mind if you come from the
probabilistic graphical model background
like myself
what do you see when you see hidden
variables well you run em
if you come from compressed sensing
dictionary learning background
and girl will talk about that and that
actually did come from there
or from matrix vectorization it's very
similar you have hidden variables
and you run alternating minimization for
several years i was going to several
machine learning conferences and asking
people
so why nobody is doing alternating
minimization
the answer ranged anywhere from
because we don't do it with neural nets
that's it because it doesn't work we
tried
because it's not written in the book and
finally asked
ah i tried doesn't work don't waste your
time
and marguerite renzata tried to do it
with her nance and it didn't work that
well and he said why didn't jan told
me not to waste time on that
i said well the problem is he told me
and it didn't change anything see
i know i know really well what you mean
and my manager had a good point and he
was worried
you can easily waste a lot of time on
this but
but uh it's actually interesting because
i mean there are some
classes if you achieve decent
performance you get algorithm with
different properties and
i think it's always healthy to have a
toolbox
a set of tools rather than one hammer
that you're going to use
for all size nails so this is another
tool
potentially or this kind of class of
methods that might be sometimes helpful
again still at the high level what we're
looking at
is a formulation that uh
method of auxiliary coordinates looked
at as well and pretty much
young caesar's dating
is objective of your fit forward neural
network you have your lowest function
you have your output y you have
basically
the function of the last layer
and weights there and then you write it
down as a compound function
as usual just like indians see this you
can rewrite it and produce a
strain formulation you just explicitly
put the activation variables
and you say what they supposed to be
equal to and
the critical part we're going to be
using the three activations
linear codes it's just more convenient
i'll show why there are
multiple methods some use non-linear
some use linear some use both
objective and you actually cheat a
little bit instead of
doing through lagrangian you replace all
their efficiency
from him so this is exactly a career
companion type of formulation
and simplify the other card the question
is now
okay we can see
yeah whatever you call it
the only problem is that it didn't look
like in the literature people tried to
provide the online uh
algorithm for that so it was page
using you know alternating minimization
them whole matrices
so yeah sorry i just want to make sure i
understand
so ultimately got two different
loss functions one of which
is just your yeah what is it just a
constraint and the other
is just making sure that you're meeting
uh try to be close to what you should be
so
what you should be is number right yes
because it is in neural net
it is linear it's before you applied
only
so this tells you this should be close
to what it
actually should be if you have your you
will never define regularly
but i will relax it and i let it be a
little bit off
not too much though yeah and the
nonlinearity
is all the next layer yes
it's just for reasons i explain a bit
later i mean there are several ways to
do that and
you don't have to do it this way
basically okay
it's all simple and then you just do a
very simple thing
oh did you have a question
ah what was it
um capital city
let's see our small c that is like okay
so basically
this is a matrix if you collect all
their
okay imagine you have the input vectors
x you can
say you have a matrix capital x
where all the input x's are collected
same thing for c's yeah
again so it's essentially w here means
all the weights and the um capital c
means
all the codes at all layers full matrix
yeah it doesn't have to be like here it
can
it's it's a simply linear gaussian
variable and now you just got your bass
nerd
you can call it neural network
whatever you're called
uh really was here yeah value was used
here but in principle you could use
whatever
you just will implement each layer
you have the three port values
allow a slightly different value
for the word loss
the difference between the two is the
thing we're looking at is
the
right forward right essentially yeah so
just
you can say i added noise to those
activations so they actually became
variables to optimize because before
they are not variables they always have
given the input they have
deterministically same
the deterministic functions of the input
now there are no deterministic functions
anymore
the stochastic functions or random
variables that's all
again nothing new here yet this is
formulation
but then online is
something new
yeah so offline for obvious reasons
will not scale to either large data sets
or what we were interested in continue
learning although we didn't test it
here in this paper on continual learning
and non-stationary
tasks that step four
okay so here is a good question i did
because i mean this is just
one way to do that perhaps not the best
way
lots of room for improvement
that's what i'm saying there are so many
design choices because
you can do it once so basically what's
going on
now what you do you need to still
propagate that error somehow
take the clause and you start updating
those codes life and target propagation
but the difference is
then once you update them you fix them
and once seeds will be fixed
that will decouple the whole chain
into multiple parallel updates at each
layer
for weights weights will be just updated
in parallel and that updated price will
be very easy because
it will be like a quadratic function
training the network to be more like
that yes
so this is more specifically i thought
people may want to see
code more specifically
here okay
so here we are
you you keep the symmetric weights yeah
so that problem is
i mean it's not it's not feedback
alignment it's not a target pro
the only little bit more biologically
plausible part is that activations are
now
explicitly handled and they are noisy
and updates are parallel but again
that's why i say it's like
working what it's it's in the same kind
of category as
target pro but they were a little bit
less
plausible but the point was okay
plausible or not
like uh how we optimize it differently
the input input is trigger as i said
that you
upgrade codes you pretty much at each
layer starting to
solve the optimization sub problem for
the codes
in the paper i can write it down but
that's where
non-linearity matters and that's where
you have to implement whatever you want
value
or anything yeah so it was all in my
torch
and in principle i think we didn't do it
but you can
go deeper into fight torch and uh change
the updates there but a separate
conversation we can have offline
anyway so you solve sequentially
so this part is still sequential and
here is kind of think about
parallelization
when there are other algorithms the
previous ones uh
career per pinyan they used that
formulation and patch setting they were
completely parallel
code wise and weight wise
but if you online it seems like you will
have to sequentially propagate
each sample or each mini patch so the
only parallelization that remains is at
the weight level
but it is better than nothing so you
solve all your
optimization for codes and now you
essentially do your rate updates
ugly and by the way there are two ways
to do that
uh say now you have all the codes fixed
have all the code fixed each layer sub
problem
for weight updates is totally
independent of other layers
and uh okay
there are at least two ways to do that
you can simply perform
sgd step but locally on those rates
independently not computing any change
or
you can use a trick that uh used in his
online dictionary
where all this stuff is coming from
actually
old old paper from whatever you remember
[Music]
there was an interesting trick there
which gives your
basically two covariance matrices
which can serve as a memory
and uh it remains to be seen if that
memory can actually
be burning but that's what i
i'm curious to figure out so either you
do simple sgt and actually
empirically so far it works better or
you do the following thing
that's what you need to solve at each
layer definitely
okay this this is peeps
those kind of room top and bottom of
that layer
and uh solving for weights is just this
simple
soft square right but it's online
problem
you don't want to keep the whole thing
in memory you don't want to keep
a bunch of samples the whole history the
whole point of online right
so what you can do again not just
you can write it or actually it's a
difference
let me write this function in this form
of these two traces
where you have two matrices
that effectively accumulate the outer
products
of codes between layers
and uh
outer product yeah so
yeah so what is across players and
another is visible
so essentially it's a co-activation
makers one is cooperation within layer
and another calculation dependent
because essentially this problem is
exactly online dictionary learning where
w it's just like piggyback on them
and the reason we got to that because we
were pre initially just doing the online
dictionary learning
and changing architecture and we wanted
to have something like that
cage architecture in the whole deep net
anyway so there are those two ways to
optimize it and
how much time do i have listen
okay okay so you do that
uh you ask kana to prove theoretical
results and she does
anyway i'm not gonna go into that and um
like if you'd like we could
go over the paper but bottom line
what it says that this alternating
minimization or even weaker version of
that because the result is proven
we wanted for much weaker version of the
algorithm which assumes that every time
you see a sample
or mini batch you only do one sgd step
in one layer and you move on and for
that
even kind of less
well slower optimization yeah if you
start
not too far from local minimum you'll
get there
it's basically just a senior chair you
have a result of the
quality of the game
look it's nothing like what my role had
in that paper
i wish we had that
okay okay but but it was good because
what he was showing
was different type of result not that
okay it will convert fine
what he was showing that if you have
stationary distribution
and you do your online approximation
of the true objectives that you would
have if you put all the data
you'll get a dictionary or the weights
not the same ones
but same quantity in terms of objective
function we don't have that result
actually it's a it's probably possible
to show
why not it's just i don't know how to do
it with more than one layer
anyway i'm divergic as usual uh results
okay so we didn't do imagenet
what we did essentially was to see if
this kind of makes sense it doesn't have
to beat everything but at least is it
making sense is it competitive on tender
things
amnesty far fashion numbness stuff like
that
some simple rnas and yeah pretty much it
kind of
matches performance of sgd
adam and such it's interesting that it's
also
often learns a bit faster so you could
possibly even use it as a good
initialization
and even smaller data it learns so
let's see what's going on on a mist
right
uh again architectures were simplistic
just like
everything like a few layers you try
hundred dollars five hundred notes this
and there same
support uh one point was to show what
happens
to all these offline methods there was
kind of state-of-the-art offline
operationalization by taylor from my
stml 2016
and there was offline yeah that is
way way way behind so it says who cares
because everybody will compare with sgd
and adam anyway but
just just saying that it's like
by far better than doing it offline
and in terms of sgd and adam
and they were kind of comparable and
same thing
so that thing was our method
like am and
then adam
[Music]
then if you zoom in
that's what i was talking about it
overlapped a bit faster than
added very consistently faster on our
nails also so we open sources
first faster learning and then they both
kind of get this
i don't know why is that i cannot
guarantee
faster learning or faster convergence at
the beginning but that's just empirical
observation
i mean so it's kind of sometimes better
or similar
and then we just again we played with
relatively
toy things
it's comparable again it learns faster
and then
it's the same as the other
algorithm was offline and
parallelized by data parallelized not
later
otherwise how would they manage that uh
that was a clear win because basically
admin of taylor it was getting to this
benchmark
and we were getting there with 0.01
percent of the data
so okay so basically offline uh
auxiliary variable methods definitely
we're out of picture very quickly and
yeah one more thing we tried uh your
first paper from
icml you had this basically a
binary network uh binary network but
just was interesting to see like what
it's gonna do
on those non-differential nonlinearities
that's pretty much as
well performance wise as what you write
here but again it doesn't faster
it just essentially gets same accuracy
but less than 24 your picture showed
about 200 and folks to get there
so it's kind of
behaves comparably somewhat better
sometimes
worse and so so bottom line it's kind of
a
it's algorithm that performs reasonably
well
at least on those things we tried
so far yes you have some theory which is
good to have
just for sanity check but it doesn't
help you improve performance
as most of theory
but the interesting thing is the
algorithm has very different properties
so it
by definition does not have the chain
of gradients so you can imagine trying
it in
romance maybe or enforcement learning
and so on although i suspect if the
problem is inherently hard
and there is a reason for vanishing
gradients then
probably any other algorithm will have
some other problem maybe
the alternating minimization well
there are probably no free lines if the
program isn't here
by capturing the demarians so you've got
the a or the b majors i don't remember
which one
that one captures the covariance of the
very and you're probably weakly second
one
probably much much more reverse voltage
perhaps
that remains to be checked so the good
things are yeah
weight updates are parallel and
independent so
if you need speed up there you can do it
if you have something extremely deep
maybe it will be helpful uh no change
that's fine if you need your
non-differentiable
nonlinearities it's easier to code
at each layer just a separate
optimization for that than
having to think how to maintain a chain
or just ignore nonlinearities all
together like people do with
straight through estimator so it has
those complementary properties
it does have its minuses because
honestly
after that we kept trying and we tried
on like
serious size resnets and it didn't work
well
and then basically what it was doing it
finds on training data equally good
solutions or better solutions so it
optimizes as well as
and then it doesn't generalize yeah
welcome to
the good question about flat minima
deep minima whatever it is but why on
earth
it finds better solution and essentially
overfeeds
we tried regularization with sparsity we
actually started with that
didn't really help so bottom line
and by the way it's kind of very seem to
be very
kind of sensitive you don't regularize
or you over regularize
and some trade-off in between seem to be
hard to find
it might be it may be different
regularization that you need not
sparsity
well it's a good question so there are
several good questions
so there is lots of work to do with that
because it's it's far from
really well i mean you can add it to
your toolbox right now but it would be
probably better to improve it there are
many ways to improve it and as you
mentioned right now
the whole uh idea of just doing one
iteration of code updates followed by
one iteration of weights
we tried to do it multiple times but it
was never really systematically tuned
there are all these decision choices in
alternating minimization schedule
that can matter a lot and that remains
to be explored
pretty much
i think i'm done
so okay i think
i uh i think it is a very interesting
algorithm and i
appreciate the points
but in terms of the biological
interpretations like
i guess one of the things i wonder is so
you're saying it's online
but like it's not actually properly
online right because you have to do a
forward pass through the network
and your backward pass is just
calculated
and then you have this that's right it's
actually worse than this
that's right no i mean it's just this
but just like sgd like you feed it one
sample
and it processes it it encodes it right
and then it optimizes it
so in that sense it's online i mean it
doesn't require
any well i mean we can discuss joshua's
extra point but here i think you will
agree with this it is
as online as sg yeah it says online as
gd right and that was not something that
alternating
minimization matters yeah they didn't do
that
yeah so now it is as online as sgd and
as online as uh target pro
so now it's at least as online as those
guys
and so then i guess my question is
though like what do you actually
see as so as i said i think it's an
interesting algorithm and i think
the theoretical convergence
it's not about brain it's about uh
as i said like i i'm very pragmatic
when i say you are inspired if it helps
it helps let me let me
argue
train this big
local competitions
processing
has all kinds of ideas
not completely free well it's between a
second order
what is possibly things that look like
second order effect i think they're
crucial
the second one and we've seen this and
especially specific cases
is you can start maturing your cost
functions as long as they
you know keep a bit of the information
you still get the
the conversions and this is i mean
they're not seeing this
other people like eugene didowski have
seen this we've seen this
you've seen this that's the point is
is how are we going to butcher the way
we propagate the information
uh that that is either biologically
possible or better for the kind of
hardware
systems we have
i know i mean ideally if you could do
completely parallel computation would be
wonderful
in online right now it's only partially
parallel right
the only parallelism is weight updates
and you still have to
propagate their activation sequentially
so it's not in that sense it's not
completely
maybe yeah and as i said there is so
many
so many design choices in this algorithm
regarding the schedule of alternating
minimizations which could be crucial
uh which are not really explored and
well i forgot to say
the most important thing just like with
everything else
hyper parameter optimization was the key
yeah and of course we spent as much time
hyper parameter optimizing
sgd adam this thing here just to give it
fair chance but still it's
it in a quite um what's going on in
going to perhaps conversion yes
convergence is computing the solution of
the system sure
and it takes time completely yeah
but okay so here's the second question
which i think is
so like so so my guess is going to be
curve become
unorthogonal to the gradient
unknown orthogonal to the gradient
so in fact this is still a way of doing
gradient descent
to some extent yeah
it's just doing it yeah yeah
yeah cool it it just uh just
breaking the chain pretty much yes
for various numerical reasons what about
yeah the neuroscientific reasons as i
said i am
help if it helps helps if it's not
completely connects well what can you do
but the goal is like we had experience
with neurogenetic
online dictionary learning which was
inspiration for similar algorithm
and uh unsupervised setting where
architecture would be expanding and
compressing
and as inspiration was good and for
neuroscientists it was a
simple computational model showing why
its
computationally kind of advantageous
to have adult neurogenesis when
environment changes
then you have more of it and you can
show that or
ai folks they said okay good paper
accept just remove your genetic from the
title please
well we didn't we left it anyway
the fact that at the end of the day
we'll make a very small change
of the weights
we're gonna make a small change and
because we're gonna be doing online
right you can't you're not gonna be
going to have billions of updates each
of them has got to be very small okay so
what the implications of this
there's more points in looking at values
of the activations
that are very different from the ones
you have in your feedboard
because anyways the only thing you're
going to be able to do is love them
only a little bit by the way
so the pump stations you're doing with
perfect properties
the only case where my argument fails is
when
uh you have like discrete
yeah like binary nets yeah then of
course
yeah you just argument doesn't work
because you want a big change
yeah could be so yeah for binary nets
that was
that's why folks at ibm were interested
in that thing
for neuromorphic and other like hardware
uh they're still interested yeah so
anyway um what i wanted to say also i
mean all this optimization of weight
stuff
reminds me about the reason i clear
paper what exactly is the title but
basically that
weights do not matter they can be random
right a proper architecture
what do you think about that one
we should discuss it in reading group
i'm i'm curious
yeah yeah yeah okay but yeah maybe we
can take it offline i'm just curious
because what did you
show are you talking about
so that that is basically just a
different training algorithm
okay david haas paper is the one where
they literally just take
they initialize they optimize on the
network architectures
find networks that can operate with
random variables
and it's like stable to their weights
pretty much it's like robust to like
whatever
almost whatever you give it to it
architecture is robust
the funny thing is so here's what they
ended up doing
is they have to optimize networks that
work
with a single weight value how reason
they do that
is because it takes too long for them to
search through networks
where the different synapses can have
different arbitrary well it's
interesting and this gets back to the
issue with any kind of evolutionary
approach
it's great if you have
well random weights is a separate whole
separate topic because
i was uh also curious about again a
clear paper
on the echo state nets which supposedly
work
not the liquid whatever so basically is
the word computing
that doesn't work it was it was
supposedly doing better than our
nan's and the lstm so okay
on which test pretty well okay so it was
some
language task again yeah although it
kind of made me
curious just to do a bit of a literature